Bilder aus besseren Zeiten in Sibirien
war in der deutsche chemie-riese BASF
und Gazprom ein neues Gasfeld ein
[Musik]
was aus vestibären nach Deutschland
bringen und für uns Unternehmen bedeutet
es eine Verstärkung der Partnerschaft
mit Gastro die Partnerschaft mit Gazprom
ist heute ein Problem denn auch Monate
nach Kriegsbeginn lässt BASF in Sibirien
gasfördern gemeinsam mit Gasprom und
Gazprom ist der wichtigste Hersteller
von kerosinien Russland und beliefert
die russische Luftwaffe die ukrainische
Städte bombardiert
im März dieses Wohnviertel in chennife
für Menschenrechtsorganisationen
Kriegsverbrechen
der Sprecher der ukrainischen Luftwaffe
erklärt Russland braucht für seine
Angriffe vor allem eins Treibstoff
ohne Kerosin können Militärjets nicht
fliegen um ihre Kampfmission zu erfüllen
sie brauchen große Mengen Kerosin
woher kommt der Treibstoff für russische
Angriffe die Spurensuche beginnt der
türkische luftwaffenexperte adamelotoglu
identifiziert das Wrack eines
jagdbombers der beim Angriff auf Jenny
Heath abgeschossen wurde anhand der
Kennung auf dem Leitwerk
das ist ein taktischer Bomber ein
Düsenflugzeug das für den Angriff auf
Bodenziele entwickelt wurde
und Adam evolutoglu ist sich ziemlich
sicher wo der Jet mit seinen tödlichen
Bomben stationiert war
als wahrscheinlicher Kandidat gilt der
Luftwaffenstützpunkt morosowski der
relativ nahe in der Region gelegen ist
wer lieferte das Kerosin nach morosowski
frontal und Spiegel haben
hunderttausende Lieferdaten ausgewertet
um den Weg des Treibstoffs für den Krieg
ausfindig zu machen
die Recherchen zeigen der
Militärflughafen von morosowski erhält
seit Kriegsbeginn Treibstoff aus der
Raffinerie in Omsk der größten ihrer Art
in Russland sie gehört Gazprom dem
Partner des deutschen Konzerns BASF
zuständig bei BASF ist das
Tochterunternehmen Wintershall der in
Kassel das betreibt im fernen Sibirien
gemeinsam mit Gazprom sogenannte Joint
Ventures Gemeinschaftsunternehmen die
fördern neben Erdgas auch sogenanntes
Gaskondensat das ist ein leichtes helles
Öl
eignet sich das für die Herstellung von
Kerosin frontal- und Spiegel liegen
Analysen des gaskondensats vor wir
zeigen Sie dem Chemiker Axel Friedrich
der war beim Umweltbundesamt früher
zuständig für raffinerin wir sehen dass
ihr in den kondensaten von beiden
Bohrlöchern hier Produktqualitäten sind
die ich direkt benutzen kann um Kerosin
das heißt Chat für herzustellen die im
militärischen Flugzeugen eingesetzt
werden können
aus Gaskondensat kann also Kerosin
hergestellt werden
wintersaldea erklärt dass mit
Gaskondensat hergestellte Kerosin eignet
sich aber nicht für Militärjets
für den nachschall und Überschallbereich
und damit potenziell für eine
militärische Nutzung wird die in
Russland auch von Gazprom produzierte
kerosinmarke TS1 nicht eingesetzt
stimmt das die Ukraine besitzt selbst
Militärjets aus russischer Produktion
der Sprecher der ukrainischen Luftwaffe
erklärt uns die können sehr wohl mit
Kerosin der Marke TS1 fliegen
moderne Herstellungsmethoden erlauben es
uns verschiedene kerosinarten
einzusetzen auch TS1 und RT damit fliegt
auch die su27 und die su34
das geht auch aus diesem
Betriebshandbuch hervor herausgegeben
von der staatlichen Militärakademie
Moskau für den Überschalljet su27 darin
steht
das Kraftstoffsystem wird mit RT
ts1-kraftstoffen oder deren Mischungen
in beliebigen Anteilen betrieben
ein Einkaufszentrum in der ukrainischen
Stadt crementschuk im Juni es ist gut
besucht hier schlägt an einem
Montagnachmittag einen russischer
Marschflugkörper ein
22 Menschen sterben
Human Rights Watch nennt diesen Angriff
ein mögliches Kriegsverbrechen
zuvor hatte Russland mariopol
bombardiert in das Theater der Stadt
hatten sich Familien geflüchtet allein
dort starben hunderte Menschen nach
einem Bombenangriff ein weiteres
Kriegsverbrechen
die bomberjets starteten möglicherweise
von der Militärbasis Engels auch die
wurde nach Recherchen von Frontal und
Spiegel mit Kerosin beliefert von der
Gazprom Raffinerie in Omsk
Louis Wilson von der
Menschenrechtsorganisation global
witness sieht deine Verbindung von
Kerosin für russische Luftangriffe und
dem Gaskondensat das sind Sibirien
gefördert wird
dieses Gaskondensat fällt bei der
Erdgasförderung an es ist ähnlich wie
Rohöl und kann zu Diesel und Kerosin
verarbeitet werden beides ist wichtig
für Russlands Krieg gegen die Ukraine
keine Armee kann ohne Diesel oder ohne
Kerosin Krieg führen
ist wintersal der mit seinem
Russlandgeschäft zu einem Teil der
russischen Kriegsmaschine wie geworden
der Konzern weiß das zurück man
verurteile den russischen Angriffskrieg
unsere Joint Venture Gesellschaften in
Russland beliefern nicht das russische
Militär mit Gaskondensat
[Musik]
der Konzern erklärt weiter in den
Fördergebieten in Sibirien werde das
Gaskondensat direkt am Bohrloch an
Gazprom übergeben
die weitere Verwendung liegt allein bei
Gazprom wintersheidea kann hierauf
keinerlei Einfluss nehmen
frontal und Spiegel liegen interne
Dokumente von gazpromfirmen vor die
zeigen gefördertes Gaskondensat gelangt
zunächst über eine 700 km lange Pipeline
bis nach surgut
in dem Städtchen so gut verarbeitet
Gazprom das Kondensat in einer großen
Anlage hier hat Winter saldea links
keinen Einfluss mehr darauf was damit
geschieht
fest steht Gaskondensat gelang zunächst
per Pipeline nach so gut von dort fahren
nach Recherchen von fontal und Spiegel
Güterzüge mit Gaskondensat zur
sogenannten borowski-anlage die wiederum
liefert Millionen Tonnen Gaskondensat
per Bahn unter anderem nach Omsk zu der
Gazprom Raffinerie die beliefert nach
Recherchen von frontal- und Spiegel 10
Militärflughäfen mit Kerosin seit
Kriegsbeginn
nach Bekanntwerden der Recherchen
fordert die ukrainische Regierung eine
offizielle Untersuchung in Deutschland
das bedeutet dass sie den Krieg gegen
die Ukraine unterstützen
damit Kriegsverbrechen vorliegen
das sollte von der deutschen Regierung
gründlich untersucht werden
wenn sich aus dieser Tätigkeit von
wintershaldea ein Kriegsverbrechen
herausstellt dann sollte der Fall dem
Internationalen Strafgerichtshof
übergeben werden
Winters haldea weist den Verdacht in
Kriegsverbrechen verstrickt zu sein als
haltlos zurück und erklärt warum einen
Rückzug aus Russland nicht einfach sei
so verrückt es klingt es braucht für die
Abgabe oder Veräußerung von
Unternehmensanteilen in Russland die
Genehmigung des russischen Präsidenten
Russland verlassen das sei die beste
Möglichkeit um nicht in die
Kriegswirtschaft hineingezogen zu werden
sagt der russland-experte Janis kluge
doch wintersal dea zahlt Monat 4 Monat
Steuern für das geförderte Erdgas und
Gaskondensat an den Kreml wir zeigen
kluge die Berechnungen von Frontal und
Spiegel es geht um viel Geld wir kommen
auf 428 Millionen Euro seit Anfang des
Jahres halten Sie das für plausibel
ausgehend von der Menge des geförderten
Kondensats und das geförderten Gases ist
diese Zahl aus meiner Perspektive
realistisch wahrscheinlich sogar eher
etwas konservativ geschätzt die
Bundesregierung hat jahrzehntelang die
deutsch-russischen gasgeschäfte
gefördert was sagt sie zu den Recherchen
Nachfrage bei der Bundespressekonferenz
wird die Bundesregierung nun im
angesichts des Krieges ihren Einfluss
geltend machen dass solche Kooperationen
die möglicherweise den Krieg befördern
ihr Ende nehmen
also ich kann mich jetzt konkret zu dem
Inhalt des Artikels auf den sie da
verweisen nicht äußern aber wir sind mit
Winters Heil im Gespräch man ist im
Gespräch
wie lange noch die BASF-Tochter
wintershaldea in Russland Geschäfte
machen will das lässt der Konzern offen